uh starting with the daily wire report
President Joe Biden ginned up racial
tensions at the graduates because we
need more of those at the graduation
ceremony for Harvard University on
Saturday claiming that America's
greatest threat comes in the form of
white supremacy
Biden gave the commencement address for
the historically black college and
university at Capital One arena in
Washington DC and we have a nice little
clip of that let's check it out
stand up against the poison
white supremacists I did my inaugural
address to a single out as the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu
I say Wherever I Go
greatest threat to the Homeland is uh
white supremacy he says
greatest threat
it's not guys like Jordan Neely that are
walking around in our cities and
randomly assaulting and killing people I
mean that's happening every single day
every single day in this country
there are people being randomly killed
and assaulted and accosted as they're
walking down the street or sitting on
trains
or doing anything else
every single day every day there are
there are gas station clerks that end up
trembling on their knees on the ground
begging for their lives when a
gun-toting criminal comes in to Rob them
that happens every day also
every day there are people sitting at
stoplights they look over they got a gun
stuffed in their face they're getting
dragged out of their own car and
possibly killed in the process
by some by some nihilistic empty person
no regard for human life at all and will
happily kill you over a few dollars or a
car or something
that's happening every single day
and in almost none of those cases are
there are they white supremacists who
aren't perpetrating these crimes
almost none of them
I mean it's it's
so rare that white supremacist does
something like this that any time every
single day if you hear a story about
someone being randomly shot or killed
um
you could just immediately assume you
can make some assumptions about the
perpetrator and none of them should be
that he's a white supremacist
the first step in growing up and being a
real man is getting off your parents
phone plan getting your own cell phone
plan gives you a sense of Independence
and responsibility it's a step towards
becoming more self-sufficient by paying
for your own finances you learn how to
budget and manage your money there are a
ton of cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into a horrific contracts and will
tack on hidden fees at any chance they
get that's why I'm a huge fan of pure
talk there are no contracts no hassle
you could cancel at any time Pure Talk
is also giving you the free 5G Samsung
Galaxy phone whenever you sign up for
the 55 per month unlimited plan plus hot
spot today they use the same Nationwide
Network as major carriers so you get the
same coverage everything is exactly the
same as far as you're concerned but you
get a much better service with pure talk
it's so easy to switch over you can make
the switch keep your cell phone keep
your phone number and do it very quickly
with their Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee you don't see that everywhere
so go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Walsh to save 50 off their first month
that's puretalk.com promo code Walsh
puretalk is simply smarter Wireless
but Biden says they're the greatest
threat uh DHS secretary mayorkas was
interviewed uh shortly after the speech
and he concurred
the President yesterday uh at his
commencement address for the Howard
University graduates called white
supremacy the the major domestic Terror
threat in this country is that correct
uh it tragically is you know um in the
terrorism context domestic violent
extremism is uh our greatest threat uh
right now individuals are driven to
violence because of ideologies of hate
anti-government sentiments false
narratives personal Grievances and alike
and regrettably we have seen a rise in
white supremacy
anti-government sentiments yeah those
because that's
that's the thing they're really worried
about
that's the kind of quiet part out loud
aspect of this
where they're really worried about are
those anti-government sentiments
and they want to tie anti-gov
quote-unquote anti-government sentiment
to white supremacy so if you have
anti-wall if you if you have
anti-government sentiments then you're a
white supremacist
which makes most of us white
supremacists because there are a lot of
reasons to have anti-government
sentiments about this particular
government
and when I say this government I mean
the one that we've had for a long time
um a lot of reasons to have a negative
sentiments about
uh
the powers that be which makes you a
white supremacist
unless unless of course your
anti-government sentiment is focused
entirely on local police departments who
you say should be defunded and wiped out
so that you can carry on coming all the
crimes you want
um they're not worried about that kind
of anti-government sentiment so the
anti-government sentiment that drives
mobs of people to invade a police
station in Minneapolis for example and
Burn It To The Ground okay or drives
people to set Federal courthouses on
fire
they're not worried about those
anti-government sentiments those are
okay those are understandable those are
just people who are hungry and want some
bread and this is the only way they know
how to do it
if you're anti-government it's really if
you're anti-government sentiments are
more intelligent
than that
and more well uh considered and thought
out than than it's white supremacy
according to them
there's no you know there's no factual
basis to any of this of course there's
no way to justify any of it the claim
that white supremacy is the thing that
like
it is for anyone who is worried about
this you're worried about the rise of
white supremacy I can tell you right now
you are eventually going to die
and depending on where you live there's
a not insignificant chance that you will
be killed
one of these days
but fear not
it is not going to be a white
supremacist who does it
and I could just say that to you right
now anyone everyone who happens to be
listening to me listening to me say
these words right now it is nearly
certain
that you will never be physically
attacked by a white supremacist
it is not nearly certain that you'll
never be physically attacked or killed
at all
but it won't be a white supremacist
that'll do it for us today uh have a
great day everyone talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed